DONE A GREAT JOB.
>> Dan: WALL.
GET HELP.
SABRES WORK IT TO THE FRONT OF
THE NET.IOUS GAMES.
HE CAME IN WITH
MacKINNON DRIFTING OVER TO THE
MacKINNON.ANDND
HE KIND OF DUST IT IS OFF ONCE.
AND SLIDES IT ACROSS ON A TOUGH
1-1
HOOK, DROP THIS ONE HERE, POKED
AYOUT NOW.
AVALANCHE, THEY WIN THE RACE,
LIKE RIGHT THERE.
HE SHOULD BE CUT OFF  THE
PREDATORS ON THAT PARTICULALA A
HERE.
THE AGAIN.
SCORES!
SECOND
NICE PASS BY SKINNER.
HE WAS LOOKING STRAIGHT AHEAD
AND HE THREW
THAT QUICKLY, THE AVALANCHE
FORTH.
MacKINNON FOR RANTANEN AT
CENTER.
CAN'T GAIN
BACK WALL, COMES THROUGH THE
GOALTENDER'S LEGS, BACK OUT T K
ONCE AGAIN FOR THAT LONG REACH
NEAR THE BLUE LINE.
AVALANCHE C
COLORADO JUST AWAY,
AND THE SHOT BY NICHUSKIN GOE TN
MAKAR.
>> Rob: CALE MAKAR JUST ONE
TIMING THIS IN THE FEEDHOPS AWA.
NOW  GO
TOWARDS THE NET.
NO GLOVE PASS SAYS T OF THE
STICK AND HE GOESX
TUCH PUTS THE PRESSURE ONLY.
THOMPSON IS GOING TO JUMP INTO
THIS GAME TIED AT 3 LATE IN THE
TURNED OVER IN FRONT!
SAVED BY
LOW.
LOOKING IN FRONT, BURAKOVSKY.
HE IS FORCED HIGH WITH IT.
AND O
THE AVALANCHE TAKE A 4-3 LEAD ON
A SHOT BY ALEX NEWHOOK WHILE
THISING THE PUCK
BACK TO THE NICE BACKHANAN KEPT
SKINNER.
HE LOST IT. COAST TO
COAST, CROW EIGEATES